[Music]
hey guys welcome back to our channel and
today we're gonna be doing chinese
husband tries mexican candy so we have
uh my childhood favorites here yeah so
we did the last video like this we did
was mexican wife tries chinese candy in
which i showed tiff all my childhood
time candies yeah that i grew up with
yeah so we're flipping the script today
yeah and a lot of you guys have been
really looking forward to this video and
so have i because i freaking love my
childhood favorites and like just
mexican candy in general i just i love
it and it's always really fun to have
him try like the candies from my
childhood because
chinese like palette is very different
from mexican palette chinese palette is
subtle and yeah what i can tell from
mexican kenny you're giving this
packaging is like punch in the face yeah
yeah so like canelo alvarez coming at
you with some flavors yeah so uh mexican
flavors you know we love our salt love
love love our spiciness like spicy stuff
a tamarind flavor is like very prevalent
in our mexican candy yeah like it's just
a lot of like strong flavors that are
just really like a lot of people
especially asian like my asian friends
who have had mexican candy for the first
time they're just like whoa this is
overpowering like i can't handle this
because this is the face they make yeah
cause like a lot of asian cultures are
just really used to like really subtle
um like cleaner especially sweets when
it comes to like candy and sweets
chinese people really like subtle
flavors and then if anything it's like a
plate of fruit
for dessert like they don't really go to
ham on sweets but now being with a
mexican
girlfriend fiance wife baby mama uh for
10 years mexican baby on the way for
almost 10 years you've been with me and
you've slowly developed this palette to
handle mexican candy but before we get
into it i want to give a quick shout out
to our sponsor babel
one of the world's best language
learning apps you have been using babble
for some time now
in spanish on and off so
progress has been paquito
[Laughter]
yeah so now with this baby coming you
know it's it's been very important for
us to really connect reconnect to our
culture that's where we're doing these
candy videos
you know like you get to learn my
mexican side i get to learn your
cantonese side and so when the baby
comes we can really just try to engulf
them in both of our cultures
yeah so then that's where babble comes
in to help us brush up on spanish
because even me like i haven't we we
don't use spanish in this household that
often kind of try to like every day
before we have our dinner we'll be like
one pro and that's like the only spanish
we have throughout the whole day but
yeah but like with babel though it's
able to help even me just brush up on my
spanish because because of the fact that
we don't use it so often in this
household i tend to forget a lot of
spanish so i'm talking to my family in
mexico and i'm like eh eh
like i just forget so that's why babel
is super convenient to have yeah it's
really cool because babel has been
scientifically proven to help you speak
in just three weeks and if you don't
have a whole lot of time like us babel
offers short interactive 10 minute
lessons to let you squeeze in whatever
learning time you can yeah and the cool
thing about babble is that these lessons
are created by actual language teachers
so they help you with
practical real world conversations all
right so what do we want to learn today
i like learning about food in different
cultures let's try food in latin america
oh that's my favorite taco los tacos al
pastor
in each region of mexico there are
different dishes and specialties however
there they also share combinations of
both local and european ingredients
local ingredients consist of el
agua
whoa that's avocado wait aguacate is
avocado in spanish
i thought avocado is spanish
i think we're about to eat some of that
in this video as you can see babel
teaches more than just the language it
teaches you about the culture the
history the people behind the language
and so much more and if you're not
satisfied with babble they have a 20 day
money back guaranteed so head on over to
the description click the link down
below for you to get 65
off a six-month subscription of babel
you know we're heading into the new year
why not learn a new language so check
out babel in the description
now let's get into this
video you ready for uh torture for some
spicy torture yes another another good
way to learn spanish is to just eat
mixing candies right
so let's do it
we have a multitude of candies here i
actually wanted to like fill up this
entire table with candies like there's
like a pinata exploded here yes exactly
but it's not pinata pinata say right
pinata
pinata
so which candy do you want to try first
i would like to go with the
lightest candy how about that like kind
of like sushi you will start with the
lightest fish and work your way towards
the heaviest yeah flavor that's a good
plan because you don't want it to like
overpower the rest of your palette yeah
it would be the oblast oblaz are the
lightest ones oh you got to be super
careful these things fall apart the
moment you touch it yeah these are i
call like i call them paper candy like
they're literally like really thin
pieces of paper so the way i do this you
kind of have to like it's like rice
paper yep super careful though okay just
slide them off
i hate how the paper gets stuck to the
paper though this last one always gets
stuck all right so the way i like to do
it like i said it's like taking my first
communion or like the community to just
put on my tongue you know just like let
it dissolve if you want or you can just
chew it whatever you want okay cheers
[Music]
so good ah so good i don't know how do
you describe this flavor
can i describe it with all honesty go
ahead be honest
it's like eating cardboard yeah
i call it cardboard too sometimes
there's a flavor though what's the
flavor that you pick up like the wafer
flavor without the sugar like there's no
sweet at all
it's just pure wafer
but it's not like the wafer it's kind of
got a stale wafer-ness to it too it's
like stale yeah i would describe it like
that too and this is the fresh kind yeah
they're not stale
these aren't ash tails
like crunch you wouldn't get it with
stale overlays i could i literally
couldn't inhale
a whole thing of these which i just held
something
okay i wouldn't consider this candy but
if this is candy this is some healthy
healthy candy i know that's why i i eat
these guilt-free that's a good like
palette starter right appetizer yes yeah
all right so the next one i'm gonna have
you eat is masapan you've had this
but i would say this is like the second
tier
palette it's a mexican challenge to open
your masa bun without cracking it oh
like with your mouth okay no
no like the whole game here is to open
it without cracking it at all you have
to have like a perfect mascarpone
because this is a powder like it
literally is every candy trying to open
it without breaking it
just these two actually the rest are
fine i was never really good at it how
easy is it to break these oh
easy so easy
you broke it i feel like i'm in squid
game yeah
this is our mexican squid game
yeah so like the whole well hold on i
forgot to emphasize at least for me in
my family like my my cousins and my
group of people i grew up with yeah part
of the masapan challenge is to have like
a perfect plastic too i died yeah i died
too it's not very perfect oh it smells
so good though this is candy so masa bun
is a peanut candy so if you're allergic
to peanuts i feel so sorry for you you
won't know what this is like at this
point is when i personally break it some
people bite into it
yeah i like to break it like this okay
cheers cheers
[Music]
oh
mm-hmm i don't even think that was a
bite i was just more like i touched my
tooth to it and it broke off i told you
it breaks so easy
so good
when i was a kid i would eat like five
of these i can't believe i had like
the capacity to eat that much sugar now
you get empa
yeah i didn't get it
how do you describe that so that's a
word i taught casey that we have in
spanish that there is an equivalent of
it in english but it's a really hard
word that you know it's not very common
but it basically means when you're like
eating too much sweets and you're just
like sweetened out like you're just like
no more sweets yeah it's like you can't
take i'm gonna like there's like a my
jaw gets weak when i when that happens
for me like i get like a film in my
tongue in my throat like a sugar film
where it's like well that's what i mean
my favorite spanish word
yeah you use that a lot that's the one
word that i don't know the english word
for so i'm just like we did look it up
though
there is a new english equivalent it's
not as fun to say
yeah
the best are you good i finished mine i
got involved i like halfway through oh
no we still have so much more to eat
okay next one is going to be tuvalin
these always come
in the pinatas you always have them and
they always
come with this guy it's a little stick
that you eat the duolin with
you like scoop it this is a classic in
the mexican kids childhood
thing i'm most curious about this one
because it's
wet kind of
oh it smells good
yeah so i grew up with the strawberry
hazelnut one there is also actually we
have it in here somewhere but there is a
vanilla chocolate or vanilla hazelnut
whatever i always thought it was
chocolate going up but now i know it's
hazelnut this seems like
a dip for something else like you would
have like a cracker or a cookie yeah
like the pocky or what are they called
oh yum yums yeah those yum yums yeah
there's like a japanese
thing where it comes with the
chocolate or strawberry dip and it's
like little cookies probably hazelnut
too it's probably the same thing yeah so
the way i like to eat it eat these is
like i used to like to get both of them
yeah i would do the yin yang approach
yin yang twins
cheers cheers
oh they made these more flimsy i
remember when i was a kid they were
sturdier what do you think time to rough
you got it
oh i did i had a sweet tooth
[Laughter]
[Music]
my chinese taste buds cannot handle this
no it's really good though yeah i've had
i haven't had a luwaleen since i think
like my early 20s so like over a decade
i haven't had this candy eating it now
i'm like oh yeah it's really sweet
but it's also like transporting me back
to my childhood like flashback time
right now i remember running around a
party after we just hit the pinata
trying to eat this but then i would
always lose the this freaking stick what
do you do so i would just like lick it
with my my whole tongue or my dirty ass
fingers i'll just get in there and just
eat it like that man being a kid was so
fun you really don't care about a lot of
things
mm-hmm
okay
you read the paper oh no not yet really
but um this is good good combo hey
i never thought about that you're such a
you're such a foodie
just don't eat the paper
it's like a wafer chocolate wafer now
yeah pretty good that was a good combo
it was mixing the oblazo
i would have never thought of that these
are all pretty intense but i think maybe
the lesser one would be the pikagoma
yeah so these are delicious these get
stuck stuck to your teeth though oh yeah
cause these are gummies
it's like someone just took a tamarind
just like
cheers
[Music]
it's like so intense it's spicy
oh man i'm not used to eating this stuff
anymore so i definitely feel heartburn
building up
especially with this pregnancy i've been
getting more harper
that's good though stuck in your teeth i
like it when you're stuck in my teeth
you have to save some for later
you're just like playing like with your
friend you're like
that's pretty good i like that one it's
intense but once i got used to it i was
like i mean it's like being woken up by
your parents to go play with your
friends but like when you passed out in
the car or something you're like why
aren't you showing at the party or
whatever and then after a while you're
like yeah
yeah that's that candy for me
those will do next okay another tamarind
candy looks like these are all like kind
of like
so this is a similar palette uh i wanted
to tell you about it break something
already no you didn't break it but i was
gonna tell you how i eat it so these
guys it's like a hard tamarind candy so
you have to suck on it for infinity and
beyond so the way i would eat it
is i would just open the end here and
like squeeze like just have half of the
candy come out and eat it from the
wrappers that could hold on to it young
tiff who had like a tiny little mouth
who couldn't fit the whole thing in her
mouth so that's the reason why she did
it that way hold it like a popsicle yeah
like that why is it in a shape of a
peanut it's not a peanut it's a shape
with tamarindo
once you work your way through and the
inside there's like this tamarind
filling
it's really this is hard candy yeah it's
a hard candy okay
cheers
you could try your best to break into it
but
good luck playing like
you got it
you see the middle
no
okay let me try because i just remember
from my telehead it was too hard yeah it
hurts i can't do it you also have
freaking mega jobs not really finding a
bite there you go i got it wait
there's no filling in here
did they change them or do i remember
wrong yeah i guess i remembered it wrong
it's not there's no filling
you haven't gotten any filling huh
yeah same tastes good though
a little bit spicy
the tamarind cook this baby's cooking
you like it baby you've had the chinese
candy now you're having the mexican
candy getting the mexican pumpkin
thermites the stuff the mexican yeah so
next one we're gonna do is this one now
this one for sure has something in the
middle here we go
this one looks spicy yeah they can be
kind of spicy look at this guy this guy
right here his little figurine red
figurine
he looks like he's up to no good
he looks like he's like i know something
you don't know
oh now you're doing accents i mean
i know something that you don't know
it's in the color of a watermelon is it
wow yes it is watermelon flavor so see
it's like red and green all around so
yeah it's not it literally says
lo cochas sabor sandia which is
watermelon flavor in the middle of these
though
from what i remember you better not fail
me okay it looks like there's a feeling
there's there's like chili powder in
here there's like a that's my favorite
thing about these
cheers
[Music]
people bite through these ones
you can
alright
oh that sounds like you broke your tooth
mmm you spicy yeah look show them
boy spicy can you guys see the middle
the spiciness that's the good stuff
right there and if i was a kid i would
like this one a lot
it has like such a strong watermelon
flavor too
eating candy is one of the funniest
things to stare at i feel like there's
that persian experience in the candy i'm
like this is fascinating guys
wow
[Music]
[Music]
what it was like a drug
oh really biting through all of it it
releases all the flavors all at once
[Music]
yes i got it i keep chewing
get that heavy dose
i would eat so many of these that
sometimes i would get tired of the
watermelon hard candy part but i just
really wanted the center part i'd suck
on it until i get to a point where i
could bite it like i just did i get all
the chili stuff and i throw out the rest
of the hard candy that's one way to be
healthier all right next one is
pulparindo
parindo puparindos they actually have
a ton of different flavors
i have some here because when we went to
the store to pick these up i'm like oh
let me get some extras there's
watermelon there's chamoy but we're
gonna do original
we'll see these for another video
tamarind fruit candy yeah it's like a
fruit leather yep
so the way they read it in english it's
hot and salted tamarind pulp candy this
looks like hot flakes it does huh yeah
that's why i'm saying hot flakes reminds
me of tamarind it does cheers cheers
[Music]
you don't like it too crazy too intense
okay i get used to it
i'm waking up to my nap mom
i don't want to play with josh over
there yourself
sometimes as a kid i would get these and
i roll them into balls i would like bite
into the ball if you're doing little tip
version yep
getting the full
childhood experience yeah see what
little tiff was up to
you understand my wife better
throw candies
no you bite into it
that's a lot that's why i bite it like
this
oh it's a lot
let's just finish off the hard candy
stuff
even though the last one wasn't hard
candy
[Music]
yeah so it's a watermelon shaped
lollipop covered in chili uh you see how
the stick is also covered in chili you
need the steak as a child
i was about to tell you
but i would eat it but if you think
about it it is not protected at all so
you're literally picking up some
germs of these times not a smart move
what did i just do
cheers
cheers
[Music]
that's pretty good this is pretty close
to the
brand name one
oh my god you're drooling it is amazing
oh it's activating my thingies there's
always one side that has way more chili
than the other side that's the one i
attacked first
oh yeah it is this is a sour one yeah
but it's only the coat the coating once
you get past it
it's just like regular candy you gotta
train harder to be a mexican
all right this one's gonna be next the
lucas custano of course does it work
like this too like yeah
so you shake it mix it and you twist the
top and then you literally just have
like an injectable thing so this you
just stick it in your mouth or go like
that but what i used to like to do is i
used to like draw designs on my hand and
then make it what kind of designs did
you draw i don't know like a star a
heart
dripping
didn't make any design try it
[Music]
this is alcohol okay hold on let me see
[Music]
oh yeah it seems weird is this what they
usually taste like i haven't had these
since i was a kid hammer and flavored
hot liquid candy try again no it's not
old it hasn't expired yet
[Music]
oh
did i get it i think you're good yeah so
usually people just squeeze it in their
mouth
like a baby bottle i just push it
[Music]
no i'm eating this more and yeah it's
supposed to taste like this oh i'm
literally getting home to heartburn
right now i'm too old for this you guys
i used to chug these
[Music]
rico
rico that's how you do it okay
look at that
[Music]
this is like tamarind
yeah tamarind candy you just push it out
and the whole thing is um
it's kind of like it's we're supposed to
be seeing like this dude's hair pretty
much like they're pushing out his hair
it's like a meat grinder it's growing
hair man
[Music]
give it a haircut
what a face
i didn't break that
i'm pretty sure i have saved this one
for last one's really intense
it sounds good if you want some extra
credit after you push it all in what i
used to do is i used to push it all out
and then you eat off of the white part
and you eat off of the green part and
there's just a whole bunch of tamarind
candy in there you can still get because
if you just push it through you throw it
away you're wasting so much candy
there's so much in here that you are
just throwing away
there's a lot
i think i'm done last one is the
knockoff version of the chili powder
from my childhood so it's a spicy one
this is a tangy one tangy first
okay this is your favorite all-time
favorite well when i was a kid and they
used to have the other one it was i've
never tried i've never tried the
knockoff one the trick to this you first
lick your your hand
so it sticks and then make it into like
a little bowl
oh yeah i could already tell it's not
the same there's a different color here
cheers
[Music]
this takes the cake yeah
wow take the cake for what makes it
sound like cappuccino
i don't know if it's even sweet it's
like it's just salty and sour
let's try the chili one
[Music]
[Applause]
this one has way more lime in it it's
not spicy at all this is way more limey
this one's not that bad but it's
definitely not the one that i had in my
childhood it's not the same not like
this one's more sweet okay
i am empanada
you just had to stick that whole thing
in your mouth yes that was the moment
when i kind of checked out for sure and
it was at that moment that he regretted
his actions okay my favorite was
definitely yeah tell me your most
favorite one the one that you would go
back to time and time again i would
definitely go back to this one time and
time again what's it called
but the close second was
yes
that's pretty good yeah well uh you're
gonna have to get used to these flavors
because this kid's definitely gonna try
it for some of this yes
actually this was pretty good too but
with the wafer though with the oglias
it was close it was pretty good yeah
like for me personally like i said i
haven't had a lot of these since i was a
kid so eating them right now i'm like
oh
it's intense i i can't hang anymore and
oh my god like i said i could fill up
this entire table with mexican candies
and this barely scratched the surface of
what i can i can show you there's a lot
more chinese stuff where
all that stuff came from too so
we do uh chinese drinks versus mexican
drinks chinese chips versus mexican
chips pastries chinese pastries versus
mexican pastries anyway thank you guys
for watching make sure to check out our
other video where casey was showing me
his chinese candies and i was trying
them out you can check that one out if
you haven't seen that one yet and make
sure to check out our sponsor and the
link in the description let us know what
suggestions um you guys have for these
types of chinese mexican videos like
what other things should we do yeah bye
peace
[Music]
you